okay so these is your drilling your
biomechanics is what you're trying to do
don't make it aerobic don't make it
conditioning we conditioned in on the
swab right right okay so and we're not
racing it time to learn form I'm trying
to get a more of a kinesthetic
unconscious competency going so that
also there don't milk anything so you
got you know we guess Rick I don't want
you to squeeze it but you do need to
close your hands okay do you use not
like this so common things in this key
position in the final position so again
the foot overturn it's common because
you want to eat your hip it in there and
you overturn the foot and now you your
foot and your hip or going yes
the dress the angle you want you also
have the opposite right hands power nap
so you turn them right here into the
technique but this is structurally
unsound because I'm falling this also
tactically the attack does not come from
the right the attack comes from the left
the attack is coming from the left
you're not going this way you see once
watch the the deviation angle
how much of it before I hit on the line
okay so I pointed this way
No I'm off the line off the line off the
line off the line and then I finally get
back on whereas when I come in this way
I'm already at that midpoint of the
first one of the right back and it's
going this you guys see that okay so
although the right hand is the power
hand pull it's not the reverse punch
okay it's not the right hip is not the
power hit then as you see you start to
lean if you kind of goes together so
things go together this pan becomes some
weird-ass thing you're almost doing me
go to yourself okay well that's how we
disarm people as we go through detail
because you put a head so you're going
to hit it on that so don't over contort
your hand and in conjunction with that
when people over contort their hand the
whole body starts to lean you see and
now you have that other problem again
relatedly people just have a come ahead
where their head so on this way this
and your fall so here here boom
how far do I turn it well that would be
too far what's comfortable where I can
keep that grip that's where I can keep
that grip so that's what I hold it then
look at me falling don't come back up
you see I can that milk too far come
back up here back to the entire drill
boom - boom here at this part people one
on hunch don't hunch
boom hit that same you see say where
your posterior chain going
these came in you need to stretch here
who but dropped parallel to the weapon
also incorrect it's not marriage
described I'm trying to get over the top
of the force line boom here then we've
drawn the job for it and we're just
going to break into Canada
well make sure is you get to third Joe
you're down here this is where you hit
contact there then the movement
continues
Oh
[Music]
all right so rule dozens one is you
should just do what I do what I'm saying
and then understanding will come later
when you have a contact if I'm speaking
one language you don't speak that
language right or I'm speaking about
something you have no idea what I'm
talking about
it sounds like more binders to you
there's no point in trying to think your
way through it just do what I'm saying
alright so here he goes the drill goes
this part here a lot of you are not
doing the skill set I want
I the skill is his weapon stay there
I bet zero pressure I stay a zero
question and I say stop I came off did
you see that was wrong and that's as
wrong as this stay there life feel the
stickiness of the weapon
came off
okay because it's not a blog and you're
filling in that it's a plot but if you
were either someone who had to defend
themselves with a job you would go
that's a piece of move or if you
were even an architect or a bridge
builder an engineer with the weapon in
the the block position where's the
distal end and who's got the maximum
leverage I do hold it up place do you
see
did I come with a four-foot piece of
steel well let's say it does not cut
through your wood weapon you're still
going to get checked out even if you
could in fact because you could hold it
up you would get checked out at my next
move I would be too fast for you buddy
so we're not doing a blog there is no
blocking right here if you ever see
yourself blocking you just automatically
go I'm doing it wrong
the smothering so you watch that in your
style this is training training is also
not largely viable I keep the initiative
so I go cool it's really just one
continuous advancement on the guy do you
understand so watch it again go slow
continue to it alright how do I learn
this modern angle well I'm gonna be on
one side I have to learn to get on the
other side without creating angle of
incidence on his booking I need a
complementary
drill that's all the practicing right
now think of the snow opera sort just
angle and then to harmonize my body with
it
if I start moving like that you can
always look back at your body is this
the right torso angle no is that where
my hands are supposed to go
is this the two timings for both hands
they look like they were doing the same
thing
watch right hand is moving and left move
no method is not moved you see let's
just like
not out here under my sensor heat so we
just take the first part here very light
listen to the sound
this sound not that okay just that over
and over ten times as patrols the good
thing about weapons is that it
reiterates the lesson its inches and
seconds man if you guys have no
awareness over that concept and then
when we pick it up you're not gonna like
weapons you're gonna scare the out
of you because you're gonna hurt this
out of you you understand the last
major incident we had the guy was shot
through his pant leg that's under an
inch
have you been even put in a worse
position febrile artery probably gonna
die okay we didn't have they didn't have
anything anything in place for that kind
of immediate medical care we're doing
the building searches right I told you
I've got lucky in the last few time but
it's all ages and seconds okay same
thing here so when he goes out you
cannot move up the circle unconsciously
by taking that foot forward of your hip
you have to stay outside finish the cut
don't you moved in didn't you again do
you understand what I want you to do
excuse the back come on you do this
first part good now we're going to show
where his rages okay you got it
I have to stay outside of that range so
I can't step take my left foot here I'm
inside that range you have to from his
cut picture is available to come friends
so this single radius so you have to
move out so that you are out of that
range not like this inches in seconds do
you understand so when you do your drill
you can come here you are in
from his radiance oh the way I said I
wanted to touch my clothes do you
understand that's what I want back
if you should be able into it everything
I walked with my body level it's the
same way you into it free attack
indicators that was gonna go a I'm going
to attack you
okay so this is training it's not extra
it's not demo okay
you should tell what how my body close
my breathing pattern my gaze everything
okay so here he goes this is where the
technique happens okay let's go so we'll
get to the end goal okay when I see he's
taking a Kenny and then his Academy
continues when I go ahead and do the
linear dress so at this point you see
where my weapons okay I hit what I
is people following him past weekend he
has exited the technique dokie you're
not fighting him anymore okay stop he's
not part of the forum when he throws
himself out of this nd here oh so you
start to see that see that and that's
the structurally unsound ankle or the
ski because you're exposing the top
spine of the weapon so it's slightly
down don't take these gross angles where
you follow the guy okay he's out go